ça y est nous sommes dans la compétition
c'est donc la bataille de coton ville
jéhan vous dire que c'est pas gagné
parce que pendant les derniers tôt ils
ont essayé de s'entraîner c'est une
catastrophe et s'est trouvé le gagnant
je t'embrouille après là ça va vraiment
delà du hasard
j'en arrive à être la force franchement
c'est très compliqué de rester debout le
compte de ppp twitter il ya ce maxi mois
il faut la gagner
voilà vous êtes fixés tant ses tantes et
en deux points
dans mes points n'ont pas évident je
prends mon temps je suis bien
m
bien et bien la guerre
habib
[Applaudissements]
devenir embauche à temps c'est vous et
je vais vous aider parce que visiblement
vous alors à temps voilà là mais qu'est
ce qu'ils sont maladroites mot serveur
lalalalalala c'est pas possible c'est
pas faire à temps d'écouter peux vous
dire que comme ça mes petits gabarits
sont à mon avis favorisés alors je
rappelle que les questions oculaire à
savoir un poème dieu je ne pourrais pas
partie
et de courage c'est vrai que
éventuellement le courage mon groupe
c'est vrai je le dis alors non
qualification de tiffany en soi va faire
bernard montiel façade
mamy gervais attention attention là je
voulais des dvd des petites chicanes
alors là attention voilà attention les
pôles eip en fait hurler le bien c'est
rappelle que le vainqueur sera
normalement série devait maintenant je
devrais très bon et ça c'est loin mais
il faut que je fasse tout ce bel
équilibre
à mon avis on ne m'a jamais allé et vous
découvrirez je vous le dis attention
mais attention amis mais attention elle
alors donné qu'il y comprend rien alors
c'est pour l'attention de construction
voilà jamais c'est à désarmer la
remontée sur l'auto mais le message soit
possible il avait le premier qui remonte
games qui tira les et dépêchez-vous j'ai
trop joué
alizée maintenant je vais vous aider à
les y manie à la dre
je n'ai jamais vu un tel désastre
télévisuelle moi je pense que ça dépend
des questions de sécurité
mais c'était préférable nous avons
souvent la compétition bravo bravo mamie
qui signifie pour moi un peu de calme
monsieur mon cher monsieur vous allez
affronter ses pires des cas vous allez
affronter
voilà j'ai allaité mes démons place
jeune femme était balisé
si ça pouvait pas de ne pas durer une
demi-heure pour réparer merci beaucoup
pour l'instant qualifiés tiffany et
bernard attention vous attendez attendez
attendez une chronique
attention voilà jean geste important
c'est aussi de tomber sur moi
voilà je le désert je pense qu'un point
c'est suffisant à moins à moins que ça
est vraiment très très 13 fois ça va
déjà qu'il faut une demi-heure pour
rester debout autant vous dire que c'est
très dur enfin pas content
alors la complexité de ce dossier
remarqué comme c'est une structure
gonflable
ils sont sourds diplo eux mêmes sur la
sociaux qui est gonflé donc il sait
c'est pas très stable voilà c'est pas
simple du tout pas ça du tout si on est
d'accord c'est pas du tout [ __ ] c'est
un excellent équilibre
alors est ce que vous avez à tenir les
amis auxquels haïtienne dont lé père
dinis comme sur trois j'arrive pas à
tenir debout
voilà là c'est vrai c'est un succès pas
possible à ce qu'on dit il est un petit
gabarit plus à mon avis à mon avis on va
terminer le jeu à 20h30
attention c'est bon non mais vous êtes
alors
ça fait rire avec van gogh remonter à
bout et aidés mais déjà essayé qu'il ya
de si tôt enfin celui qui allait tenir
au moins 10 secondes remporte points
mais celle ci est pas possible alors
allez-y gilles bien c'est mal et il a
compris s'ils cèdent avec le petit
canton de villeréal easy attention mais
non mais alex si vous n y vois c'est
mieux attention 3
je ne sais pas
je sais alors arbitrage déni c'est moi
je pense que non non non attendez je
vais demander à la régie merci à
permuter
voilà attendez je pense que l on aille
et paix j'ai passé je ne sais pas j'ai
une jeune fille de chocolat est ce qu'on
a mais là c'est bon alors pour moi il ya
on a eu le ralenti pour monter un match
nul il faut il faut finir le remettez le
casque allez-y et c'est tenir déjà sur
le clos mais le tri c'est pardon la
chance aujourd'hui
non pour l'instant il ya quasiment
sixième manche
on a toujours un peu pour eux ce n'est
toujours pas la tête alors fait ou dit
reviens c'est vous avez à monter son
époux pas à tant de tapant dans la tête
allez-y on a pas trois heures attention
attention si on fait pour le point de la
victoire
attendez le top attendait le top
attendait le top 3 2 go
il a cassé sa qualification en jean
alors je ne sais pas qui on a dit non
non non génie valait là alors est-ce que
kanye là donc vous vous vous êtes où
vous voulez pas le faire alors vous
allez faire une défaillance proposition
vous êtes obligé de faire une manche à
balai j'ai pas fait c'est quoi ton fils
on en est en place et j'hésite parce
qu'en fait comme comme on manque du feu
mais comme on monte
non on a on a on a eu 1 on a eu un
rapport de la soirée j'étais content
mais on a eu un fort c'est kelly qui ne
faut pas casser dans l'épreuve très
justement géraldine gay
gilbert montagné normalement et
géraldine cents et 3 go c'est mettre à
jour non mais alors à quoi bon si vous
êtes désastreux oui mais moi aussi
beaucoup trop gros et bien pour les
détails
allez bon c'est vrai que plus on est
grand plus c'est compliqué parce que
forcément le soleil était tombé plus bas
peut pas t'aider mais attention vers la
lune 3 2 mais je n'ai pas les matches de
la presse qu'il y ait beaucoup et j'ai
cogné un essai comme hier les allées
donc s'il n'en avait qualifié mais c'est
dur donc contredire à d autres merdes
il est très fort mais je pense que c'est
une erreur encore l'attention
alors donc fini mon voisin s'est plus
que jamais affronté mais bon la taïga du
grand narbonne
bernard oui j'avais dans la télévision
les casses le casque non ça va
ouah je serai vosges a remis un casse
mais bon attention attends attends
attends
attention alors qu'ils m'aident
attention non ils sont pas très grands
donc ça devrait
c'est simple pour attention madame
heures et après tout personne qui m'a
dit comme ça va mais à 3
maj c'est pas normal
alors le point et bout moi vraiment
italie à bord des années s'est réalisée
remontée remonter avant monte jamais de
voter qui tombait annoncé bien avant on
me dit que c'est bien c'est moi
remonté bah allez allez allez jours mais
ça les îles bernard à les remonter
tu fais des romans tati bon voilà trois
de gagner
c'est là puisque maintenant vous allez
affronter en finale et là c'est une
grande finale la fonte et gilles verdez
deux cas c'est pas obligatoire attention
attention les amis s'est doucement
doucement doucement mais oui je suis
saisi mon vernis
justement je vous rappelle que le
principe du jeu est simple celui qui
tombe le premier a perdu c'est quand
même pas compliqué et fusaient mais ça
fait vingt minutes on joue à ce truc là
c'est hyper dur rien vous restez debout
en fait vous ne pouvez pas aucun
équilibre possible
attention attention à bon en deux pour à
mon top 3 points 2
boucher
normal non attendez j'ai remonté à
bordeaux un point partout ça se joue
maintenant et m'est tombé dessus et non
mais c'est normal c'est le possible
partout j'ai pas gagné non un bravo vous
êtes tombé à rester sur le web sur essai
c'est ce point chaud se joue sur ça si
vous avez joué
gilles verdez où attendait bernard
montiel peut-être que c'est pas faux
mais bon goût attention attention 3 go
je sais toutefois alors voilà les
défauts que sert il fallait beaucoup à
renoncer
sa tour
[Rires]
j'aurais adoré j'en ai adoré venir
je ne peux pas les yeux vous savez bien
bien devenu savez bien non
on va se retrouver ça va te feras tu
m'attaques labat est fragile on va se
retourner dans un instant les chiffres
avec toute l'équipe on est très en forme
bravo bernard et bernard mon père
g